a double Olympic gold-medalist and
three-time world champion over 800
meters caster Semenya
has totally dominated her sport but that
success has brought great scrutiny with
athletics governing body the IWF
deciding her genetic makeup gives her an
unfair advantage over her competitors
but she argued it was discrimination her
testosterone was naturally produced and
she hadn't done anything illegal cast
the cord for Arbitration for sport
actually agrees with her but such
discrimination is a necessary reasonable
and proportionate means of achieving the
IDF's objective of preserving the
integrity of female athletics in some
track events of international
competitions
it means caster Semenya will now have to
take testosterone suppressants if she
wants to race she's done nothing wrong
this is the way she's a lady
this is the way she was born and even
the counts of arbitration in sports as
the rules are discriminatory so how is
it fair but it's also discriminating
against the people she's racing against
we have to find ways around for both the
intersection athletes and for
transgender women athletes is how they
can be included but we also have to work
out how can we protect women's sport
because if we're not careful in 10 years
time all the world records will be held
by men in the men's races and all the
world records in the women's races will
be held by people who have a y
chromosome the average testosterone
levels for women are between 0.5 and 2.5
nano moles per liter of blood for men
it's between 10 to 34 while the I double
AF says the levels are the same in
female athletes with differences in
sexual developments which is why they've
proposed the limit of 5 for women
competing in track events from 400
meters to the miles caster Semenya
hasn't publicly spoken about losing her
appeal simply saying on Twitter
sometimes it's better to react with no
reaction but she has spoken about her
gender in the
past when when you're born you're born
there's nothing anyone can do there's no
you know scientific you know test or
anything that can define a human caster
Semenya has won her last 29 races at 800
meters the outcome of her next one if
she decides to run again might be very
different
Ashish Joshi Sky News